[Music]
hi I'm back again with Nika for more
yoga sequence so today we'll be doing a
really shot a simple morning workout to
really just stretch you out and give you
the energy you need for the day yes I
designed a very simple routine for you
guys to just help you wake up stretch
your muscles if you energize and also to
stimulate your digestion right so let's
get started let's do it so start just
laying down our back just make sure it
comfortable you can actually do this pot
even when you are still in bed just keep
your legs apart shoulders apart and
we're going to bring awareness so a
breath relaxing your whole body
breathing deeply through your nose and
before your mind just feel supplied with
all the things you have to do today take
that moment to connect with your breath
maybe setting pension for the day
and how you would like the day to unfold
how you would like to feel today
[Music]
three dp1 would you breath in and gently
exhale Oh
[Music]
slowly bring your legs together and
gently all the way up to your chest give
it a nice we might evolve and side to
side gently warm up the spine slowly
release your left leg all the way down
on the ground and we're going to bring
your right knee all the way over to the
left extend your right hand to the right
side to lose to the right nice gentle
final speed inhale deeply and exhale up
with your next challenge going to go
back up and change the side right leg
goes down let me squeeze into your chest
and then gently all the way over to the
right sending your left hand to the side
gentle sweep
[Music]
one more time all the way to the center
we do both mr. cha and then slowly try
to sit all the way every week with Ian
he'll is bring our hands all the way and
as you act he'll slowly falls all the
way almost
allow your hips to open breathing deeply
and this inhale slowly walking your
palms back
let's crease again to the left right on
your left knee left hand behind you it's
really good to start a morning with some
gentle twist to wake up your spine and
also to stimulate your digestion
let's repeat on the other side we have
survived 3G to keep your back straight
is fine for sitting all the way back to
the center get from here we are going to
bring your palms whole it and release
into our tabletop and then gently into
cat cat cat and cow stretch the great
auto back queen alicent good and it
slowly really lifting and again gently
arch your back
and slowly really really great unit it's
fine
open it up ah and then one with time our
[Music]
eating health checking your toes gentle
lift all the way up in here done
stretching our leg this is a really
great pose if you only have time to do
one yoga pose in the morning make it a
downward dog it'll stretch all your
muscles you need some of that listener
can walk in one play you can feel one up
and your back nice and flat
[Music]
Janson stretching hamstrings
and then slowly inherit start walking
forward to the front of your mat okay
turn here bend your knees keep your left
hand down right hand is reaching all the
way up Ania straightening your right
like as we go up to get an opening
number
okay looking up inhale get me here as
you exhale and we go down let's repeat
on the other side left hand reaching up
straightening your left like stretching
a lot looking up to with your palm
inhale deeply as you exhale gently good
from here you're going to bring your
palms behind interlace your fingers
slow you lift up and stretch your leg
stretching your whole back and shoulders
releasing some of the stiffness inhale
as you exhale lower your hips lower your
pump let's gently lift all the way up
into your chest
all right rapid it's really great to
energize our whole body all right judge
the fluid it surely feel sort of energy
and you hold that good eating hell is
this all up as you exhale palms together
lower again and three sort of right
reach of your digestive system look over
your right shoulder trying to keep your
hips low deep breath in here and add
claw one more time inhale lift up and as
you exhale squeeze to the other side
keeping your chest nice and open low hip
breathe feel the energy flowing through
your body inhale let's lift all the way
up again as you exhale bring your palms
to your chest from here with inhale
bring your hands all the way as you
exhale blow all the way full inhale
lengthen your spine as you exhale step
back into plank from here you can drop
your knees or go all the way down into
your chest run
inhale roll up into Cobra and exhale
into York down with them from Hewitt
inhale bring your left leg all the way
as you exhale step all the way forward
between your palms ground your right but
with neck inhale lift your hand all the
way and settle in your warrior one and
again feel the energy flowing through
your leg reduce the front of the three
to relax your shoulders and one is
inhale lift up as you exhale palms down
step back to plank and gently into
trouble
inhale Cooper as you exhale down inhale
bring your right leg almost as you
exhale step all the way full with ground
your left inhale let's lift all the way
up warrior one if your left knee doesn't
go to grade you can always twist your
foot into your highlight and three for
three
keep your right knee right above your
ankle two and one
inhale lift up exhale slowly down step
into plank and children inhale Cobra and
exhale into your Challenger let's hold
you down with a few briar you can learn
turning the spine
driving your body feeling the stiffness
and our muscles slowly melting over and
that is two and one inhale as you act
health but all the way full inhale lift
your head exhale pull as even hitting
keeping it slightly bent lift all the
way exhale risen let's move on to the
next inhale and he'll down you're going
to flow throw a breath inhale exhale
step back to plank Jen into Totoro
inhale Cobra and exhale down with that
inhale left leg goes all the way exhale
step all the way full ground your right
knee inhale hands always as you exhale
settle in your warrior two again
building strengthen our body and energy
through the legs and core breathe
shoulders relaxed releasing down another
two
and one and slowly all the way full
steps back into chattering lean he'll
cool exhale down with them let's repeat
on the other side inhale right leg
exhale step forward grounder left inhale
all with as you exhale warrior two
keep the variety right above your ankle
relax your shoulder three three two and
one
gently palms down to the ground step
back to plank inhale exhale chaturanga
inhale Cobra and AG help Dharma dog rest
in your download if you like - this is
too much you can always rest in your
childhood like a baby and three another
three lanthanum to the washing focusing
on your breath - and you can again again
he'll walk up step all the way o inhale
lengthen exhale and fold inhale all the
way up exhale through your do few more
rows with different poses in between
inhale up exhale down inhale lengthen
exhale step or jump on YouTube shuttle
run
inhale scoop exhale down
it's inhale bring your left leg all the
way up and this exhale slowly pull pitch
bringing your right leg all the way up
and you can bring the hands all the way
up into warrior three it's it's harder
for you to find balance you can keep the
hands on the ground prone or bringing in
check warrior three make sure you square
your hips lift the chest up this one
really on the dredge with this whole
body three is another two and when as
the exhales slowly really step back into
plank exhale chaturanga inhale coupe and
exhale down with them let's repeat on
the other side right leg as all as you
exhale pull inhale left leg Jamal keep
it down on the ground or if the balance
is good hands to your chest or reaching
all the way forward make sure you lift
your chest up and you square your chest
not it's too good and when exhale come
to the grass step back into plank
shuttle run inhale Cobra exhale downward
and again breathe deep in your down dog
we'll be on your breath reconnecting the
breasts and the three lanthanum to spine
to husband one more time inhale as you
exhale step all the way both inhale and
exhale full inhale all the way up and
exhale from your chest let's continue
flowing inhale as you exhale when full
inhale and exhale step back into plank
gently to children inhale Cobra exhale
down
inhale left I guess always as the exhale
step all the way forward and we're going
to play though I speak forward here
bring your hands in the back interlace
your fingers inhale lengthen in spine as
you exhale when all voids and stretch
your hands we did you hear opening up
the shoulders stretching the leg one
more deep breath in exhale then gently
drop your palm on your back and come all
the way forward step back to plank
chaturanga inhale Cobra exhale down
let's repeat on the other side right leg
is that exhale step forward ground your
books feet pointed forward bring your
hands in the back interlace you fingers
head up with inhale as you exhale gently
for hold again keep breathing deeply
here feel that nice stretch in back of
your legs releasing the shoulders one
more
and slowly drop the palms down on your
hips come through some of your mud comes
down step back to plank and shuttle run
B inhale Cobra and exhale down making
and again keep breathing me here you'll
feel the surge of energy removed wet day
definitely waking up your whole body
[Music]
inhale as you exhale step all the way
full with head up and hold inc all the
way up exhale knees inhale bring your
hands up and exhale for Nicole inhale
lengthen and I'd help step back to plank
chaturanga gentle Cobra and down with
that with inhale bring your left leg all
the way as you NGO step all the way
forward we're going to drop our rifle
down and go to a crescent truth now you
can either bring your palms on your hips
and gently just try to sink in forward
to open extra flexors you want to go
deeper and you can bring it all the way
up and gently try to tilt on the back
remember not to push in to prove you're
just slowly sinking into it going with
your breath line the hips and chest and
heart to open up
inhale gp1 the time as you exhale bring
your pump down that back to plank and
chattering inhale Cobra and exhale down
one more time on the other side right
leg goes up in here
you exhale step forward drop your left
knee into the cracks and hands all the
way or if it's not that great with your
lower back and just drop it on your hips
open a pitch heads roll your shoulders
to the back and just stay here for a
month
okay now stretch three two and as you
exhale palms little girl step back into
plank and chatter on
inhale slowly and exhale down and hold
you down dog breezy see here was free
to
and and as you exhale slowly drop your
knees down bringing it wide apart
pointing outwards I'm going to just
fancy relief into your childhood
forehead down again connecting with your
breath grounding relaxing your shoulders
slow down the bra
[Music]
one more deep breath in exhale
[Music]
and then slow you bring your palms next
to your knee with the inhale lift up
bring your knees together as if finish
it off we're going to twist gently right
come on your left your left hand behind
twist to the left look over your left
shoulder one lunch for your they justice
system to wake up and then to the other
side looking over your right shoulder
being a fine straight
[Music]
Aaron is slowly releasing the sensor and
you are done and good morning good
morning so this is it really simple and
gentle morning stretches which you can
do on a daily basis it's just a great
way to bring back up wellness to your
body and of your mind
yes exactly and every time when you have
a day when you really don't feel like
working out
just trust me get on the mat and do this
simple few stretches and you know I have
the energy to do more than that yeah
I've been doing a lot of because video
especially on the base where I don't
feel like doing any chance workout so
you can check out more yoga videos right
here with nikka
and we will be filming a lot more
exciting videos together as well so be
sure to like this video subscribe and
follow me car and you can check out more
links in the description box below
have a beautiful day I have a lovely day
guys and we will see you next time